hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to destiny rebellion another
amazingly reviewed amnesia custom story
now it's very interesting because every
time that I open up amnesia after having
not played RIT for a while and I hear
that title music I just get all these
feelings rushing back to me of like the
first time that I ever played it and all
this really interesting stuff starts
flowing back into me and I just love the
feeling of it like that music at the
beginning you know what I'm talking
about it's just like absolutely
delightful for that but that bringing
back that sense of just dread at what
you originally played it anyway this one
is gonna be a very interesting one
because this game offers many optional
things that it says could be those weird
that is this was this music anyway it
offers a lot of optional excuse me hello
is it someone over there I'm definitely
not going there there's no reason for
that I think there might be a reason
because alright fine whatever you say
but anyway um have no idea what I'm just
saying but there are optional stuff that
allows you to get very strange and
possibly funny side things going on so
anyway my name is rolf i'm a journal
enduring your german scientist and my
wife has died Oh
optional I want to do that how can I do
that
I think I may need to go to my house
first and I think on the map it said
that I was over here ha rouse house we
all have our time machines some take us
back they're called memories some take
us forward they're called dreams what is
with that that's a new thing
like that happened when I loaded up the
game originally all those weird fonts
started popping up
hello whoa blue lights said optional
blue light hello what the hell I have
read every single science book in this
room they are ordered alphabetically one
exact book is missing well how about you
go screw your books ha ha ha you
unorganized douche clean that up your
nerd anyway so there's one book missing
that I obviously need to replace in some
sort of fashion so uh hello my trophy
cabinet gained in science competitions
and conferences okey dokey good for you
aren't you just the biggest nerd nerd
I'm sorry I didn't mean to call you nerd
we're all nerds deep down inside heck
look at me I'm like the biggest nerd of
all okay so anyway this looks awfully
nice I think there are some are uh stow
hello you big creepy douche okey-dokey
then there there might be some things in
here from amnesia a machine for pigs if
I'm not mistaken but other than that I
will be other than that I don't know if
there's anything that I absolutely need
tinderboxes god it's been so long since
I've played no idea what's going on
oh damn fine a secret but good Oh what
happened did I just go to the bathroom
you I thought I might have found like a
secret thing like in Octodad when he had
to flush yourself down the toilet you
went down into the secret pipe level
well I guess that wouldn't make much
sense in this amnesia custom story hello
now there also was the option to take
this game totally seriously and avoid
all of the optional side-quests hello
this is my very important top-secret
personal journal and what to do this
Ralph's zipper I have written all
important events and plans in this
journal so I would not forget a simple
thing to avoid really long reading skip
to the last page as important okey-dokey
hey Ralph zipper that doesn't seem very
important you you tricks check anyway
today is a big day I know the location
of six nuclear fuel rods in this village
holy how I only need four of them to
successfully charge the machine with a
small reserve the rod locations are one
in the medical centre two in the
backyard rooftops doing the old on douse
one in Johnson's Island one in the music
assignee only need fourth so there is no
need to get all six okey-dokey then
I think you're trying hello I think
you're trying to drop a very big hint
that you don't want to waste any of my
time why if some of those optional
things are gonna be good for me you
always just like as for me
okay sweetheart dearest for you just a
few moments and we will be together
again
what why
picked up a medical kit I guess that's a
new love down and um oh isn't that just
delightful
okay oh I love how they actually tell me
what things do activate secret mechanism
in the living room downstairs that was
both hinted at downstairs and it was
transcribed in the book itself so good
for it hello would that do
did I Boop something good is that me my
self-portrait boy I am a great artist
also very anime styled boy that's
besides the point let's see what else is
in this up hello goodbye hello anybody
ooh sorry dr. rhino but your moral
principles are not gonna stop me I'm
gonna resurrect him just like the Elric
brothers in Full Metal Alchemist that
can't stop me they told me that was a
bad idea but I'm still gonna do it
anyway hello hello ah my good pet Phi
Donkers it's good to see you oh also my
aardvark [ __ ] or my [ __ ] aardvark
I don't know which one um
that I think it's just plain old plain
old nothing to see here
there's definitely something from
amnesia a machine for bigs of the what
pardon
doc pardon you wanna crap it's yours
right oh it was so cool
they even provided me a quick access
that's awesome god this guy this guy is
thought of everything
I'm really impressed what happened oh I
see
well let us venture down into the depths
and see what there is that I need to see
wow what the hell so I'm guessing this
where I put all the nuclear fuel rods
there just so happens to be a rather
demonic symbol on the wall over there oh
I'm not gonna worry about that just yet
I need the I'm pretty sure this is where
I need to take the nuclear fuel rods
unless I'm supposed to go in here I
don't think I'm supposed to I definitely
don't think it's good of an idea to be
in this giant meat grinder thing okay
let's venture outside because that's
obviously where we need to be this is
getting interesting already all the
custom stuff in it now I'm ready for
some scares or laughs I know that I know
nothing no great mind has ever existed
without a touch of madness that's very
true
that's very true cuz I'm totally insane
ergo I'm a genius or something like that
the game grumps were just talking about
something to do with geniusness there's
actually an interesting thing they wash
a lot of TED talks which is something
that I Mark you guys if you guys haven't
watched any of the TED talks recently or
any of the TED talks of the past you
definitely should because they're very
very interesting topics not all of them
but the vast majority of them that
qualify for being a TED talk can
actually be quite interesting and you
should give it a try no harm in learning
more things retro house music house
Johnson's house
I think they said to throw something in
the music house but I'm probably gonna
go over here first oh come on I want to
go in the optional house oh yeah yes
we'll see what's in the optional house
first because you never know when there
could be something of delight they also
said that I might be cheap jump scares
and eases what oh are you kidding me oh
hell yeah oh I love it
is this the song from turbo dismount oh
my god I am in love this is the best
custom story ever oh my hello mr.
floating skull okay you get the [ __ ]
away from me okay that's weird that's a
little weird
oh hi what is this the disco skull okay
okay
okay this is weird this weird dog
are you kidding me oh my god this is
amazing why why actually I don't even
need to ask why usually I ask why in
this situation with this what the hell
why oh hi I actually felt you before I
saw you you're gonna be bugging me the
entire time aren't you dick
what excuse me hi boy hello mr. skull
man man look at that grunt busting moves
it's flippin awesome oh my god I love it
I love everything about this I love
everything about this I am so happy
right now oh I've never oh did you party
a little too hard he my bro well you
just need to relax over there hello oh
I'm so sorry I did not mean to hello
Punk
Oh have you dancing do you need some
help busting a groove I got aquavit a
now what the aquavit a does have no idea
maybe it gets you crunk as is evident by
all these off of those from giant
tinderboxes hey Italy you've been having
a good time good for you you work hard
you deserve to relax I think that's I
think that's all I needed
good keep up what why is there zero
gravity for just this piggy oh I don't
even care it's so cool Wow okay I'm done
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh okay I'm out of here
no no no no no no no oh my god that's
creepy in the dark hello
what is this tells this what is this
this is a nuclear fuel rod I don't even
know anymore I don't even care about
knowing oh my god is so good oh where
did I go now oh my god smash [ __ ] have
yo [ __ ] okay
one more and we'll ease you oh my god I
can't get over this I can't handle it I
can't handle hi about your fish
this is madness madness Wow I know god
damn it
but oh alright this Jeff yes yes this is
madness good good good nice observation
that you had there got that sickening
beep whoa
laughs hi friend how no oh this box
isn't tiny enough I was very I was about
to go whoa
it almost got me there but that box is
nearly tiny enough I thought I thought
for just the briefest of moments oh I
guess this is why this is here so oh
good the nice delightful music is
stopped ELLs up okay thank you and now
it's gone all bad okay never mind
you son-of-a-bitch
I can't even be mad at you for that do
you remember the good old times is rich
oh really that bad your first time
played amnesia
remember when classic amnesia was scary
some jump scares became retro the
teleporting naked guys for example
because no one ever liked that
this room is retro it contains button so
you can try actually getting some retro
jump scares if you want to well I think
I found all the buttons so I don't know
if there's anything else for me oh my
god there's got to be one more it's got
to be one I'm missing come on give me
another button if only found three need
another come on ah that's it okay damn
it
okay I think I've discovered everything
there is to discover in this place I got
the aquavit eh I don't know if that's
actually like a nuclear fuel rod or what
I love it I love everything about it
I'm also sweating it's so cool it's so
awesome okay I need to calm down here
because I am I'm getting far far too
excited about this oh but it's so cool
okay anyway I think no no I've got more
time I've got plenty of time I've got
plenty of time guys I'm gonna keep going
on this one what's going the other
optional one oh I love the option oh I
love it
what are we doing what are we doing here
hello player this house contains all
credits and refuses to use the same for
the custom story you're here to earlier
to be accurate to late if you want to
see all the currents Oh what huh
what does that even mean okay so I can't
I can't go in here until the end of the
game okay i get i get i get i get i get
you
I understand what you're picking up
putting down I see what you're slinging
I know your tricks okay anyway into the
music house then we go this is the first
actual house not an optional one I'm
gonna get started a little bit on this
one another move
to the next part torito's again with the
freaking letters why does it do Oh
things aren't as party tastic as they
were in the last one
why hello friend how you doing
douche okay oh okay cool things oh hello
whoa it's one could I pick up a sofa
looks like this guy works out it's
midnight or maybe the grandfather clock
is broken so is there anything I can do
to that not yet
oh hi Ludwig von Beethoven Beethoven
okay
med get the music business was doing
quite well lately but unfortunately
there's a lack of customers in the
recent months due to the plague the
customers often talk about pandemic I
created a sterile surroundings in my
house and when the epidemic is over I
plan to order the newest gramophones and
guitars I set great hopes on the
gramophone I expect that this invention
will be in vogue for at least another
hundred years
okey dokey Klaus stickler if that was
your real name
oh hello got these tiny little bitty
tinderboxes oh no you're priceless
violins
they've been borked who could have done
such a hello oh no you're priceless Vaz
thing you're priceless you're priceless
thing is very strong actually very very
strong okay grandma phone hello okay so
for reasons that I shall not go into
detail I had to step out of the house
early the music house specifically the
music house specifically anyway so I'll
come back to that later uh later on but
I'll move around the town for now anyway
this custom story is shaping up to be
pure awesome and I can't wait to play
more of it so anyway thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done check out
the other custom stories that I've done
in the past and if you are eager to see
the rest of this game let me know in the
council
thank you getting everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
how they go no there you go buddy get it
burn Oh God knows me